it looks like i'm wearing a green
jumpsuit ready to fly
not really i'm kurdish and this is my
traditional clothing
i was washing dishes in a bengali
restaurant and my friend who works there
gave me
dawa and i took my shahada in two to
three years and i want people to take
their shahada just like i did i used to
watch videos from speaker's corner
nine years ago and i'm there today with
salaam corner talking to the very people
that i used to go to listen to and guess
what some of these people that come
they take their shahadah and right after
speaker's corner we go and have a meal
together as-salaam corner we have
youngsters youth coming to us because we
tell them we're there every single
sunday they come with doubt
they come with just simple nasir
something that i would disregard
actually changes their life
brothers and sisters that is what we do
exactly at salaam corner
an outdoor hub for both muslims and
non-muslims to unite
you'll also be supporting salam corner
an open hub in central london
where thousands of people will be coming
both muslims and non-muslims
to engage and talk with us and then
you'll also be supporting our hotline
where we will be answering doubt and
even muslims who are calling to take the
shahada and lastly you'll be supporting
our gaming initiative where we will be
playing with youngsters
as young as from 11 to 18 years old
brothers and sisters
at their level answering their doubts
connecting with them on an emotional
basis
and helping them for their future what a
game to play who would have thought one
donation goes to all of these projects
where your money will be going is a
brand new salaam studio set
editing team graphics team camera team
on top of that salaam corner an open hub
for both muslims and non-muslims
brothers and sisters in this blessed
month click that donation link and
support us now inshallah